people always think there is no value to
water and what motivates me is that I
want to give whatever value as a water
so McGee I'm a advocate for water
our most important beverage on this
planet what a lot of people always say
what are so many in no way it has to be
from the onion or something like this
this cannot be real fascinated you are a
water sommelier correct and you believe
that there are many types of water and
flavors of water and then it's important
to know the distinction I'm not even
believing in that I think there is
actually its effect its water when I
started this whole water concept in 2012
he almost enjoyed that everybody said
only in LA it's a water so my game and
then I said to the people nyeh only in
LA people think water has no value but
they're living in the desert I've been
certified as a water so money from the
German water trade association and I
came over to the States on an o1 visa
for extraordinary abilities
a lot of people don't even know that
water has a tds level in the stands for
total dissolved solids
how many months actually combining on
water and there is no pure water and i
go always crazy when people saying oh
yeah what needs to be pure and then
you're calling suddenly a purified water
and no no it this is the best you can
drink because pure needs to be pure that
doesn't come from other nature itself
processed for a process through this
kind of bottled water web belongs is the
trash can i treasure
la tap water has way more electrolytes
than everything of verified water so i
have to choose between purified and a
light tap I would go for anything
[Music]
in gong-shil I'm invited as a water
solely to taste a lot of different
spring and mineral waters in a big bang
show is the first time that we
implemented the system of the different
tds levels and judging the different
waters would never be done before this
worldwide recognition from different
families around the world joining in one
place and then judging the different
categories I realized when I was four
years old and water has taste
I went on vacation time with my parents
in the different cities all over Europe
the temple that is it differently so my
parents always thought I was born with
our Sun why's he running to the sink
right away he's always thirsty maybe he
has some issues was something like this
it was not about hydration it was about
taste for me and this all depends on the
different middle levels when I'm tasting
water it's like me all my visuals are
starting to race it's not just about
taste it's even about my eyes and my
nose I'm always putting a very big hunk
of water in my mouth and to drink it as
a normal person would do it to just have
a feeling of that water and then most of
the times I'm doing a second set and
then I'm slurring around my mouth and
I'm adding oxygen through it because
action helped water to grow the same
with wine that's reason with Lauren and
sounds sometimes like very weird when
people doing this and they thing like
Arthur look at this somebody I like
[Music]
so we dress that in water it won't fool
is singing it was amazing even for me I
never had that before it was so funny
you thought like you're not
lining and like smelling like coconuts
it's insane that was when I ranked the
water
I looked for this thing with taste in
that water and when you're drinking your
eyes will open right away in like stress
lately about how Mother Nature can trade
this for you the thing it will be a good
standard for the future for people to
follow what we're doing and not have
some journalist or some random people
from the street because you wouldn't do
this with wine right but you do it to
water then showcases again like I'll buy
water
they don't need professionals everybody
can do it it's like no it's nice there's
a science behind this as well
[Music]
in China their various standards for
water production so in the world usually
the back label contains a lot of
messages so it's interesting it looks
like there's more information from the
consumer actually on bottled water again
China then in the States
yes it contains a lot of information
even just a bottle purified water that's
incredible
the states when you're thinking like
we're living in one of the most
healthiest countries and on this planet
and now it's almost standard to say oh
but make sure your water is filtered
I think it's sad in China in an Asia in
general the the importance of water is
already on a completely level
China is very aggressive when it comes
to bottled water they are already
thinking like yes absolutely water it's
not just water we need to push the
envelope there there's a way more
structure to it there's very hard
regulations as well when it comes to
bottled water what I saw so far and I
think for two reasons obviously there
are so many people living there and I
think they are realizing as far how
important water is for their like being
as well thank you very much good morning
today we celebrate water water is not
just water
we do respect food we do respect wine
and the thing is just about time to
respect water as much as the other two
and all the judges unanimously agreed
that we set a new standard here today
for how water should be treated in a
water tasting yesterday we tasted about
sixty different waters international and
domestic and I'm very excited to tell
you that the results are in it's good
I'm happy for them a little bit slower
beginnings and up but then we got into
ax t
[Music]
[Applause]
it's almost like an a celebrity status
what I have to get oneself it's kind of
scary office I'm here to educate people
and I never thought that you can become
a celebrity with water
[Music]
we have to do something in America as
well the American market we will I will
talk to the CIA about this as well
there's definitely chances to really
celebrate water in the right way
water is way more important than anybody
things we strongly believe that we are
on the right track to really move the
whole water movement forward water
should not be a luxury product water
should be a human right the water will
be the next huge big thing I think my
goal is achieved when Lisa Simpson
suddenly tells Homer Simpson that water
has a taste and maybe suddenly I will
show up as a character and go to a water
taste test stay hydrated America with me
and let's have some fun with water
[Music]
now I have to go to the restroom
talk of a model all the time
you
[Music]